the chicago bears were linked to carson
wentz as jay glazer reported they never
actually made
an offer they did some homework but look
if the guy doesn't want to play for you
why do you want him that was my big
takeaway throughout the past week and a
half when it dawned on me carson wentz
should not want to play
for the chicago bears so what will the
bears do
now that they haven't made an offer for
carson wentz and shereen i want to run
something by you
that that i've been kicking around and
it kind of hit me like a thunderbolt
alex smith makes the most sense in my
mind for the chicago bears right now
he's got the history with matt nagy he
knows the offense hell the guy knows
every offense at this point in his
career and given all the coordinators
he's worked with
but smith was good in kansas city he
wasn't great
he didn't take them to the super bowl
they needed patrick holmes to do that
but when you consider where the bears
are and where they are trying to stay
play off contender play off team keep
people employed
alex smith to me is the perfect bridge
to whatever comes next
because i look around there's nobody
else
that makes me think that guy makes the
bears a playoff contender this year
other than mitchell trubisky if they can
keep doing what they did last year
and we know the fans aren't going to be
thrilled with trubisky i i think the
fans in chicago
would at least be intrigued by the
possibility of alex smith being plugged
into an offense that he knows well
and that he that he performed well in
during his time with the chiefs
i had not even thought of alex smith but
it does make perfect sense for him to go
go there because he does know that
offense has had success in it
question is does he still want to play
and it does sound like in his interviews
and he's given multiple interviews
since the season ended that he does want
to continue his career it just sounds
like it's not going to be in washington
so that does make sense
the guy i thought of mike was teddy
bridgewater and you go well okay
he didn't have a great year do you
realize and i didn't realize this until
today
his 3733 passing yards would rank
third in bears history single season
they've never had a guy pass for 4 000
yards in their entire history eric
kramer owns a record with 3838 1995
that's amazing to me i mean i knew they
hadn't had the pro bowl and all pro
quarterbacks that we talk about and
that's been one of that franchise's big
problems
they've got to find that guy and whether
it's a bridge guy like alex smith or
maybe if they believe in teddy
bridgewater to come in and maybe the
long-term option whatever
but they have got to settle that
quarterback position to have long-term
sustain
sustained success in chicago if that's
going to happen
i'd want to go back and do full research
on how he performed in
cold and wind and elements during his
time with the vikings when they played
the bears when they played the packers
but the last time we saw him as the
viking starter
because he eventually made an appearance
as a backup during the 2017 season but
to cap the 2015 season
it was outdoors it was in the elements
it was cold
and he drove the vikings down the field
to put them in position to win the game
and then came blair walsh who
went wide left with the field goal the
26 27 yarder so bridgewater at least
with the season on the line was able to
move the ball
in the cold it wasn't necessarily windy
and it was a clear day
but it was at least cold so so may look
they could do a lot worse
than teddy bridgewater i think he's
still underrated
and the way the panthers have just kind
of shoved them to the side
has reinforced this belief that he's not
really all that good i thought he played
better
in his first season as the unquestioned
starter since 2015
than we could have expected so so that
is a possibility for
the chicago bears they don't have many
though that will put them in playoff
contention
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports